- Hey, everybody. Thanks
for joining today.
This is a presentation
from a company I'm with
called Island, and I
can't wait to show you.
This is a very game changing technology.
We're doing some really great stuff
with something called
the Enterprise Browser.
And if you've never heard of what that is,
you're gonna learn a bit about it.
You're also gonna understand
kind of how we helped
Amazon on the .com side,
do some really revolutionary
things, specifically with AI.
And unfortunately, my co-presenter, Adam,
could not make it today.
So it's just gonna be me
as we go through this.
And we will have some
time for some questions
if anybody would like to have, you know,
understand a little bit
more about what this is.
Obviously, our booth is back there,
but we're gonna have a roaming
mic as well for questions,
and there will be time
for questions as well.
So, what is the big deal?
What is the challenge here today?
Well, the challenge is that
we have these AI agents
that can do a lot of stuff,
but we need to make sure
it's governed in a good way.
And so today, you know,
we are thinking about
the data governance that
goes along with that.
It's nothing, you know.
You can do basically whatever you want.
The data, the sensitive
data goes right in.
There's really not a lot
of governance to that.
Data comes back out.
And then we start talking
about agentic AI, right?
So when it's doing things.
And it's really nice when it does things
for you from a personal
consumer type way, right?
Maybe you give it your, I don't
know, your OpenTable login
and it does a reservation, that's cute.
But then when we bring
that into the business,
we need different controls.
We need different governance around it.
So, what we're gonna talk about today
is that control in that security
and making sure it's reliable
and some use cases that Amazon found
that really helped them
drive some true value
and some cost savings
within their enterprise.
So, first, if you haven't heard
about what this category is,
it's probably the most exciting
thing I've seen in tech
for a long time.
I've been in tech for a long time.
This is super exciting.
I've been with the company for five years.
We started about five years ago.
But in order to bring in data
and think about when your data gets,
you know, brought to you.
It's brought in usually
through a web browser,
some sort of an interface.
And this is where it gets decrypted.
And today it happens in a consumer browser
that you use, right?
So, Chrome and Edge and others,
and that's where that
thing called SSL kicks in
and it does the big
two prime numbers thing
and magically brings you your data.
And so, you know, five years ago,
or about four years ago, rather,
we launched the Enterprise Browser
and now we have controls over that.
So, this brought us data
protection controls.
It brought us delivery controls.
It brought us things we could
never do before, you know,
without trying to break open
SSL and inspect the wire
and see what the data
was doing inside there.
That's getting harder
to do as you guys know.
So, when we brought this
to market, you know,
we put all the controls that are needed
to also gain network access.
So, you think about this as
really not just a browser,
but really an enterprise workspace
that gets you access to the
data that you need to get to
and governs and controls the data
as it goes in and out of the organization.
So, that's kind of the
basis of what we've done.
And since we have brought
this to market, you know,
we have some of the world's
largest banks, you know.
I think we have most all
of them at this point,
at least in the top 10.
We have some of the largest
travel companies in the world,
a lot of adoption in
healthcare and BPOs, right?
Because that's where the data leaks out.
This is, unfortunately,
this is where data, the
operators can, you know,
potentially accidentally leak data
or intentionally, deliberately leak data.
And so we have, you know,
some fantastic customers
that have proven that this
technology, you know, is real.
They've invested with us
and obviously they're big
companies that we have
working with all around the world.
So, now, we have AI, and
this is kind of where we are.
You guys are probably gonna be flooded
with all kinds of stuff
around AI today and tomorrow
and for the rest of the week.
And it was cool. It's
super cool technology.
And we started with the
chat bots, you know,
then we got into, thanks
to ChatGPT and others,
and then Anthropic created the protocol.
So, we can do our modeling protocols.
We had connections we brought
in those AI agents, right?
We're starting to also see
consumer-based, you know,
AI browsers hit the market as well.
So, those are really
focused on the consumer.
So, the challenge though is what do we do
with trusting the data?
We need to make sure it's useful
so that builders and developers
can access backend data.
But they need to have
governed access to the apps.
They need to have governed
access to the data.
And it all needs to be audited
in a secure and safe way.
And what I mean, audited,
I mean, we need to see,
you know, what do they did?
What did they do? What did they click on?
What data did they go to?
Where did they move the data?
Did they move it from this
system to a different system?
And unfortunately, in
the world of AI agents,
when that access is granted,
it doesn't know much about
the role of the user.
And so, you know, you might
have somebody that has access
to, you know, the HR system
and they could query that.
They could say, "Hey, what's the CEO's
social security number?"
And of course it's got
access to that data.
It could deliver that data,
but the context of the
role was missing, right?
And so that's when it
starts to get complicated.
And the one thing between
you and those roles
is today an Enterprise Browser.
It's today something that
governs that activity
and governs your access
to what they can get to.
Passwords. A good example
of this are passwords.
So, yes, like I mentioned before,
I don't mind giving, you know,
somebody my OpenTable account.
That's a password. Maybe I
don't give them my bank account.
I certainly don't give them the keys
to the corporate accounts, right?
But that's where we are today.
We need those credentials in
order for AI agents to work.
So, how do we do this
without giving those credentials to AI?
And the answer is the Enterprise Browser.
That's the way to do it
because that's where it can be injected.
That's where data can make sure
it's never exposed visually.
It's never exposed on the wire.
It could be sent securely.
That's a big leg up for
everything we need this to do.
This is the future.
When we start talking
about these agentic AI
and you start seeing demonstrations
and, you know, future plans for this,
this is where the rubber meets the road.
It has to be done in the browser.
And we've already built this
to create that technology
and enable that in a way
that's safe and secure.
So of course, you know, we
need to have collaboration
and this is a lot different
than the consumer AI agents.
Again, as I mentioned
before, these are useful.
These are great.
These are great for the
individual, not for the role
within the corporation, right?
So when we think about the
enterprise grade requirements
that we have, this is where
we need to step it up.
We need to say, "What role
is that user responsible for?
What do they do within the company?"
You know, "Can they have
access to that data?"
So, that's where those
Enterprise AI agents
really come into play.
And so, today, you know,
we are talking about the Island AI agents
as something that we have introduced.
This lets teams create, share, run
secure, reliable agents in the browser.
And that's the place where
you need them, right?
So, this is where we can
control the data protection.
This is where we can automate
work across the businesses.
We can keep the data protected.
So, this is agentic AI
in an Enterprise Browser.
Today we're calling it AI agents.
And just to show you kind
of how we've built this.
You know, there is a trust layer
and some of these are
components within Island.
So, the Island components
of private access,
getting you to those network
resources already built in,
you know, the components
of data protection,
you know, those layers
are already built in.
So, when you create a model,
it's very easy to create that
model with a set of skills
that are repeatable.
And in order to do this, it's real easy.
You just do it, guess
what, inside of a browser.
You hit the record button.
You go through a series of steps.
And some of those steps
might be manual intervention.
You might have somebody
that needs to do something,
approve something, you know.
After all, they've got access to the keys,
to the kingdom, and everything else.
So we need to make sure
we have that audit trail.
We have that visibility.
And having those actions
in that human oversight,
it has to be done where humans work.
And again, that's inside of that browser.
And so we've built this
with control policy
into that hardened Enterprise Browser.
It can access storage, secure storage.
What's secure storage?
Could be your cloud storage.
Well, can I get there
with Chrome and Edge?
No, you used to,
but now you have the Enterprise Browser.
That's your only way to get there.
That's also the agents' only
way to get there, right?
So we've created that closed loop system
for that agentic AI to take over
and be able to do the functions
that are needed for the company,
and of course, that full audit trail.
This includes screenshots,
you know, mouse clicks.
Where did they type? What did they put in?
What came back out? What
did the screen look like?
You know, full audit,
full capability for that.
And so, when we have this
governance and control,
you have to think about,
well, who's gonna use it?
Well, we got the mode set up
so that a builder can build
what they need to build for an AI,
for an agentic AI within the browser.
Again, do the recorded replay.
You know, we have the
access to the applications.
Those are running in a
browser, whether they're PWAs
or, you know, just basic web
apps or maybe WebAssembly apps.
And then of course,
what they can do, right?
What they can do, which
button can they click on?
Which button can they never click on?
That's kind of an important thing.
If you don't want an agentic AI
to accidentally click the
big red button that deletes,
you know, 20 instances, you
know, of your EC2, right?
That's gonna be a challenge.
That happens in a browser.
That can be an agentic AI configuration.
So, that configuration
is important, you know,
can they just read the data
or can they delete it, right?
And so, now we have that
ability to give that oversight
and deploy with confidence.
And so, we can deploy
this in a number of ways.
Obviously, you know, the Island browser,
it can be run in a remote browser,
isolated browser environment.
This is a locally running browser as well.
So, most of the activity that you do
is gonna run on the endpoint.
It's gonna run, you know,
locally with your system
on your network, with your
data, with your credentials.
That's the productivity that
we really wanted to see.
And that's what, you
know, we can integrate
with Bedrock for that as well.
So, full integration with AWS Bedrock
so that you can keep your data.
It could be, you know, stored
within the Bedrock system
and it obviously built
for scale for there.
So, what did amazon.com do?
So, again, I mentioned
that we have kind of a
customer testimonial,
and I was hoping Adam could
be here to talk about it,
but what they were able to do is
they found a way to use our
agentic AI or Island's AI agents
to build some real productivity
within some of their key systems.
And they did this in a few ways,
but the whole point of
this was that it was easy
and they put the hands in the folks
that actually knew what they were doing.
Folks that know that it's
a repetitive task, right?
If they're doing the same
thing over and over again,
they know that they could save time.
So let's put the power of that automation
into the hands of the
folks that could use it
and let's make sure it's governed
and let's make sure it's safe.
And so, you know, this
is kind of how it's done.
Pretty simple as you can
think about a recorded replay.
If anybody, you know, has
been in IT as long as I have,
you probably heard of Mercury Interactive.
We used to record and replay
scripts like Selenium scripts,
and COM, and CORBA, and DCOM,
and all these different protocols.
It's kinda like that, but super easy
'cause it's built into the browser.
So, all we do is you prompt the user
with what workflow to build
and include a set of skills along the way.
And those skills could be
click on this, search for this,
do this button, take this PO number
and copy it and paste it over here.
And that's productivity
that you can quickly
do across applications.
And again, this all happens
within that governance of the browser.
You validate it. You edit
the flows if you need to.
You add human interaction
steps for those needed.
And then of course you share
that with your department
and increase productivity.
These are the three use cases.
And I do wanna have questions
here in just a minute,
but these are the three use cases
that they actually put to work.
So, amazon.com and their
marketing teams and a few others,
they're doing some really
cool automations already
as Island customers.
And so what that means
is their purchase orders.
They're automating the updating of the,
a lot of these manual
tasks that are happening
as well as the social media
team and the marketing team
doing things across different platforms
and moving data, adding
tags to certain areas
so that they can be quickly
monitored a little bit better
with those tags.
But again, all things
that they would just be
naturally doing in the browser,
we can automate that
and make sure that they're
now governed and safe.
And again, that's that tag
creation there at the bottom.
So, in particular, I like this solution
that he really wanted to
showcase this himself,
but the challenge here on
this purchase order one
that top use case was
that they were spending,
and I think it was 30 minutes
per day for 1,000 users.
So 30 minutes per day for 1,000 users
today at Amazon right now are being saved
because they've implemented
this agentic AI solution
with the Island browser.
And basically what it is,
it's updating permissions.
It's copying and pasting PO numbers.
And before it actually gets executed,
before they actually pay that
bill, they get a little prompt
that says, "Okay, we did all this work.
Is this the bill you want to pay?"
And they hit yes in the browser
and then it executes that transaction
and actually pays the bill.
So anyway, 80, I think it's
80 cumulative hours per week,
which is an amazing
impact over 1,000 users.
That's a big deal. So, that's
what I wanted to show today.
Obviously you can see the power
when you think about agentic AI.
If you're not thinking about
what it can do within a browser context,
you're not considering
it, you know, thoroughly
because this is where the data is.
This is where you have access to the data.
And now with the Enterprise
Browser of Island,
you've got the governance,
the control, the audit,
and you have that capability
just naturally built in
to a single, you know, ecosystem
for that app delivery mechanism.
And we'd love for you
guys to come see a demo.
This is something that
I could talk about for,
you know, for three days.
You still wouldn't get it.
If you come see it, I guarantee
you it's not just a browser.
It's a true enterprise delivery workspace.
We'd love to give you a demo
and walk you through it.
We've got just a few minutes for questions
if anybody has any.
We've got a roaming mic coming through.